as i told you
uh guys earlier that you meet people in
your life and
they go on to great things they go on to
terrific things and you're proud and
you're thrilled to be able to call them
a friend and you knew them when and so
on and so forth but this is the only one
in my life
who is now the second gentleman of the
united states the first to be as such
joining me here on the rich eisen show
is none other than doug emhoff how are
you sir
rich my friend well i am proud of you as
well as you know that and um
everything you do everything you are but
first and foremost a great dad great
friend and it's just an
honor to be here with you they're a good
man for saying that i i greatly
appreciate it all right let's get right
into it did you you threw a strike right
at nationals park that actually happened
in the ceremonial first pitch that
actually happened that might have been
the most stressful thing i've done as a
second gentleman uh
i uh i practiced full regalia and i went
to a little league park around the
corner
and unbeknownst to me i was practicing a
50-foot pitch without a mound
and then i
show up at nats field and what they do
is it goes very quick they throw up a
uniform on you or a shirt yep and then
you just practice in the hallway with
all these people around and i'm just
literally bouncing the ball off the
concrete i am so nervous
and realizing that he said well you know
you're going to be off the mound
and i said how far is it i know that's
60 feet
so
go out there and i think if you see the
video i'm trying to smile i'm waving and
i do a little
okay an athletic move so i throw the
ball up okay and catch it realizing okay
calm my nerves down i can do it
that you've probably seen a major league
mound before i have not so i walk up and
it literally looks like it's 15 feet
high
it's super smooth and then the mound is
like buried in into or the the rubber is
buried into the mound
and i'm thinking i'm wearing sneakers
so i just went up there and said you
know what i'm just going to go for it
i'm not going to think about it i just
walked up wound up and threw a strike
right so uh and you can see me i just
kind of fist pumped myself
to make sure
to you know realize what a moment
because um we have seen
and my son cole decided to keep sending
me the 10 worst uh first pitches of all
time just to you know keep me off my
game yeah
he was uh messing with me and a few
other friends are doing the same thing
and then of course you know i'm hearing
from folks in the administration
uh hey good luck you know this will be
great just you know make sure you throw
it down the middle
yeah you know because anyway
you had to be better than fouchy right
like they had that was the standard the
fountain he was the standard he and he's
a great man yeah he's got to know him
very well and he's a real hero and a
real patriot but um yeah that was on one
end of the spectrum and you know jen
saki uh did a great job so i you know
talked to her and got some advice from
her and um
needless to say it was it was a big
relief and um because he can only
imagine if i had thrown a grounder and
what would have happened you would have
never let me hear the enemy no mr uh
second gentleman of the united states
douglas zemhoff no sir no because you
know uh again you don't want to be part
of that youtube
lore of course pitches you know the
fitty cent um who else we got out there
chris
carl lewis john wall mariah carey oh
yeah we can mj mj threw one into the
stance i mean it was it was uh conor
mcgregor right out of here
i think conor mcgregor hit a white sox
fan from wrigley field down in the south
side
on uh on youtube on this stuff so i
believe i looked at every single one of
these uh beforehand so i was ready doug
amhoff the first ever second gentleman
of the united states here on the rich
eisen show and before we get to uh i
guess some of the serious stuff
um how nervous are you for game five
because you're a die-hard dodger fan i
know you know
this is the one thing where the vice
president my wife kamala harris is very
serious about her san francisco giants
and um
there's been a lot of um you know
talk in the household these last few
days
we kind of expected a game five
we have it um it's coming up there's a
lot of tension in the air here and uh
you know this is the first time i
believe they've ever faced each other in
a
playoff series
and uh you know you got the two best
teams and the majors and at this early
stage so it's um
it's just being in dc it's really hard
to stay up that late rich so i've been
really had some late nights um yes
forcing myself uh to stay up and watch
these games but really excited about
tonight do you have any advice from my
buddy chris brockman here across the way
because he's a die-hard red sox fan and
uh
he is currently uh in the same household
mother of his child
is a braves fan and they might actually
meet one another in the world series do
you have any um any advice about how to
have a a healthy relationship despite
there being a split baseball household
oh man just turtle just just keep it to
yourself
well doug can't do that i can't do that
it's so public and you know they're
posting pictures and
uh and god forbid one time i walked out
of the house where i just picked up the
one hat it happened to be a giant hat
and they literally keep posting that all
my la friends like what are you doing
why are you wearing that china so i had
i live this such a public life
that i can't turtle but my advice to you
just keep your head down and keep it to
yourself yeah i mean after the patriots
falcons
three come back super bowl from a few
years ago i've learned to just keep my
mouth just turtle yeah what's the upside
yeah
seriously
what's the upside is an excellent
excellent way to go about this chris
what is just got to keep thinking that
what's the upside but his problem is he
keeps the world serious that's the
upside i mean come on like that's what
it is you can't keep it going uh okay so
i i know uh in your travels as the
second gentleman of the united states
doug that you've been visiting a lot of
uh
vaccination clinics across the united
states and you you uh again we've
established here as well you're a
die-hard sports fan so you know what
kyrie irving is saying and how he is or
what we're trying to attempt to
understand but he is he is not
vaccinated and and appears to be still
considering it
what do you say when you hear somebody
with a major platform like him
uh wondering about whether or not to
take the vaccine whether it's worth it
or a vaccine mandate is something that
is anathema to him what do you think
about that yeah i would say to him what
i've said
to folks all over the country like one
there's so much misinformation out there
so i know people need to make make a
decision what's best for them and their
families but do it on facts
so there's a lot of loud people out
there um who do have a voice but they're
basing their voice on misinformation so
i've spent a lot of time rich
debunking
misinformation i've done this with dr
fauci we've done
instagram lives and we just want to make
sure that the facts are out there
on these vaccinations so that's one and
again i've traveled to you know 25
states
been all over the place at huge
vaccination super centers at sports or
arenas i actually did a vax event before
i threw the first pitch and it's the
same thing these vaccinations work
they are safe they are effective
and it's literally as you know rich from
your personal experience
um the one thing that's really standing
between you
and being one of those folks in those
those videos that we see and you know
what they are rich it's the oh my i wish
i had taken the vaccination literally
the last words coming out of these folks
mouths we've seen those videos
safe
free effective available
and if you again i'm a lawyer so i deal
in facts and evidence so
where cases are are high and deaths are
high and hospitalizations are high guess
what that's where vaccinations are low
and where cases are low and deaths are
low and vaccination hospitalizations are
low
that's where vaccinations are high so
this is not complicated stuff this is
just basic basic stuff so if we want to
get back to
the life that we we want to get to
where we're all back to kids are back in
school
um we're back in our offices
we're back in restaurants and and
churches and temples and and sporting
arenas safely
we've got to continue and complete this
um
this uh road to vaccination
so um i'm hoping people with big
platforms like that
will come out in favor of vaccinations
we're encouraging them to do that
but um
people have a voice and it's got to be
based on facts not misinformation and
i'm going to continue to do everything i
can with this platform that i'm blessed
to have
to encourage folks if you don't want to
listen to me talk to your doctor
talk to trusted people in the community
who know what's going on and again you
don't want to be that person on your
deathbed saying i wish i would have got
vaccinated and think about your family
think about the pain that is going to
cause your loved ones and you see these
stories of dads with four and five kids
both parents dying it is unnecessary and
completely avoidable
so we need to do better and i'm hoping
that's what i would say to him and i'm
hoping he changes his mind and then
becomes a an advocate to be vaccinated
so and you know before i let you go uh
what do you say to him and others who
think that vaccine mandates are unfair
and un-american what do you say to that
you know there's there's lots of things
that that we have to do um as part of
citizens for each other like you can't
drive without a driver's license i mean
there's so many things that we're
required to do
um that we do because it's we all wear
seat belts now so there's so many things
that
are good for all of us
that are necessary
so i'm putting aside the the verbiage
and the nomenclature you just go back to
whatever you want to call it
people need to get vaccinated they work
they're effective and it's literally the
one thing standing between your deathbed
or of major hospitalization and like
yourself rich
if you happen to get a breakthrough case
it's mitigated
because you were double vaccinated and
you've talked about that publicly and we
thank you so much for doing that i
appreciate you saying that doug uh look
words i've never said to you before but
your advanced people said i only had 10
minutes
so uh last thing for you what do you
want to talk about your fantasy team
what do you want to get off your chest
listener first time caller doug from dc
you're on the air i mean so one in four
mccaffrey was our first pick this is
your fantasy team fantasy team team
nirvana
this is a league that's been in
existence since 1989 okay um it's a
bunch of law school and and lawyer
friends and now
second generation's coming in so my son
cole who's now 27 is my partner okay for
the last seven or eight years and this
time we decided we got to take this
seriously we've not made the playoffs
for four years it's almost like a
laughing stock so we get the first pick
i think i even asked you we pick
mccaffery yeah gets hurt
we think we're gonna make this great
trade we get chalk breaks his ankle
first minute of the first game we have
him
uh it's been tough we're not happy about
it we're gonna keep fighting um
but yes we are one in four it's all
right so am i
so am i and i just can't stand it i have
the people it's in my buddies league in
poker here in los angeles and
they think i i don't know football and
it really infuses me no it's it's a head
and it's you know we're getting tons of
you know what from the
the s talk in the league and now because
there's so many ways to to do it with
the online uh you know platform so i'm
getting it on the chat rooms i'm getting
it on twitter i'm getting it on email
it's just um i don't like it so we got
to change
hang in there well at least you threw a
strike when the whole world was watching
good luck to your dodgers and uh thanks
for doing this doug and i just
every time i see you
i'm doing this thing it's just so
amazing to see it's a little surreal but
you know what man keep doing what you're
doing i'm so proud of you
and like to to all the viewers and
listeners out there rich is the best
he's just a great friend he's a great
dad he's a great patriot uh not patriot
but u.s page
no brockman's the patriot yeah and uh
just such a just a good guy and i just
um keep doing what you're doing and
again folks
please get fascinated follow the science
follow the facts
you know there's too much misinformation
out there and we'll all get through this
together at second gentlemen on
instagram and twitter douglas emhoff
you're the man take care doug all right
take care everyone doug i'm off second
gentleman the united states right here
on the rich eisens show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here